Çeviri: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Bugün başta eğitim olmak üzere kadına
şiddetten çocukluk çağı kanserine,
ormanlarımızın yok olmasından sokak
hayvanlarına, eşcinsel haklarından
mültecilerin yaşam koşullarına
kadar hepimizi rahatsız eden
birçok problemle yüz yüzeyiz.
Bu saymış olduğum her bir problem başlığı
için size hüzünlü hikâyeler
anlatarak birkaç dakikalığına da olsa
dikkatinizi bu problemlere çekebilirim.
Örneğin, hepimizin yakından
hatırladığı Aylan bebeğin trajik hikâyesi
mültecilerin çektiği sıkıntılar hakkında
düşünmenizi sağlayabilir.
Peki ya sonra?
Sizi rahatsız eden bu tabloyu değiştirmek
için ne yaparsınız?
Ya da son bir ay içerisinde toplumsal
ya da çevresel bir problemin
çözümü için ne yaptık?
Bazen elden bir şey gelmez, neticede
hiçbirimiz süpermen değiliz.
Kendimizden daha büyük problemleri
nasıl çözebiliriz ki?
İşte böyle zamanlarda sorunun
mağdurları için üzülmek,
belki probleme dikkat çekmek için
birkaç sosyal medya paylaşımı,
en nihayetinde de “Nerede bu devlet?”
diyerek devlet yetkililerini
göreve davet etmek, yani probleme seyirci
kalmak genel bir davranış biçimi olabilir.
Fakat gelişmiş ülkelerde durum
bu şekilde değil,
gelişmiş ülkelerde her türlü çevresel
ve toplumsal problemin çözümü
devletten beklenmiyor.
Problemden rahatsız olan
insanlar bir araya gelerek
çözüm mekanizması oluşturacak sivil
toplum kuruluşlarını oluşturuyorlar.
Diğer insanlar da bu çözüm mekanizmalarına
yani sivil toplum kuruluşlarına
destek oluyorlar.
Mesela bağış yaparak çözüme
ortak oluyorlar.
Arkamda bireysel bağış
alışkanlıklarının dünyada
en yüksek olduğu on bir
ülkeyi görüyorsunuz.
Sizce böyle bir listede Türkiye
kaçıncı sıradadır?
Türkiye her yıl düzenlenen
“Dünya Yardımseverlik Endeksi”ne göre
bireylerin STK’lara bağış yapma
alışkanlıkları sıralamasında
135 ülke arasında tam 112. sırada.
Türkiye’de her yüz kişiden sadece
on ikisi dini ya da
dini olmayan sebeplerden ötürü bir
STK’ya bağış yapıyor.
Çok çeşitli dini inançlara sahip arkamda
görmüş olduğunuz
diğer ülkelerdeyse bu oran
%66 ile %91 arasında değişiyor.
Yani sanılanın aksine
dinin de bağış yapma kültürüyle
pek de bir alakası yok.
Fakat bu tablo bize gösteriyor ki,
biz toplum olarak yüzleştiğimiz
sorunlar için üzülüp
şikâyet etmekten çok da öteye gitmiyoruz.
Bizi ilgilendiren problemlerin çözümü
için ne yazık ki çözüme ortak olmuyoruz.
Elbette Türk insanının neden bağış
yapmadığı da araştırılmış.
Araştırmaya göre;
bağış yapmayanların %5’i
STK’ları zaten tanımıyor.
%13’lük bir kesim bu kurumlara güvenmiyor,
elbette geçmişte yaşanmış bazı kötü
tecrübelerin bunda etkisi büyük.
%26, ihtiyaç sahibi birini görürsem
ben kendim yardımcı olabilirim diyor.
Ama bağış yapmayanların yarısından çoğu
-yani %52’lik büyük bir dilim ise-
yardım miktarım küçük diyerek
bir STK’ya bağış yapmadığını belirtiyor.
Yani bu insanlar ya küçük miktarların
bir şey değiştirmeyeceğini
ya da küçük miktarların STK’larca
kabul edilmeyeceğini düşünüyor.
Oysaki küçük miktarlarla da olsa bağış
yaparak çözüme ortak olmak isteyen
bu kitleye yönelik bir yöntem yıllardır
hayatımızda: Bağış kumbaraları.
Hepimizin mağazalarda kasanın
yanında görmeye alışık olduğu
şeffaf bağış kumbaraları.
Oldukça basit ve minik kuruşlarla
bağış yapmaya uygun bir yapı.
Örneğin, 19,99 TL’ye aldığımız bir tişört
için uzattığımız 20 liranın
para üstü olacak bu “1 kuruş”.
Sizin için ne kadar önemli?
Kaçımız yerde görsek eğilip alırız?
Sanırım iyi bir amaç uğruna hepimiz bu 1
kuruşu o bağış kumbarasına atardık.
Elbette bu 1 kuruşu gerçekten
elimizde tutabiliyor olsaydık.
En son ne zaman bir bağış kumbarasına
para attınız hatırlıyor musunuz?
Ben gerçekten hatırlamıyorum.
Çünkü son zamanlarda bazı şeyler değişti.
Örneğin, hayatımıza plastik kartlar girdi.
Banka ve kredi kartlarının hayatımıza
getirdiği muhteşem kullanım kolaylıkları
yüzünden artık harcamalarımızda
neredeyse nakit kullanmaz olduk.
Bir de bunun üzerine çevrimiçi
alışveriş hayatımıza girince
ya kumbaralara atacak kuruşlarımız
artık ortada yoktu
ya da kumbaraların kendisi.
Fakat biz hâlâ minik kuruşların büyük
değişimler yaratabileceğine inanıyoruz.
Küçük kuruşlar birikerek büyük
meblağlar oluşturabilir.
Hatta daha da önemlisi, neredeyse hiç
bağış yapmayan bir toplumda
böylesine kolay bir kullanıcı deneyimi
bu insanlar için ilk adım olabilir.
İşte bu yüzden biz “Yuvarla” sosyal
girişimini kurarak artık
pek de kullanamadığımız eski tip bağış
kumbaralarını yeni ekonomiye ve
yeni ödeme alışkanlıklarına
uygun hâle getirdik
ve bir süre önce e-ticaret
sitelerine entegre ettik.
Henüz kullanmayanlar varsa örnek vereyim.
Bir e-ticaret sitesine girdiniz,
çok beğendiğiniz bir gömleği
alışveriş sepetinize koydunuz,
ödeme sayfasına geldiğiniz zaman,
Yuvarla dijital bağış
kumbarası size soruyor:
56,99 TL’lik alışveriş tutarınızı
yalnızca 1 kuruş bağışlayarak
57 TL’ye yuvarlamak ister misiniz?
Tek yapmanız gereken bir
sivil toplum kuruluşu seçmek.
Örneğin, Türkiye’de okul öncesi
eğitim önemli bir konu diyorsanız
UNICEF Türkiye’yi seçebilirsiniz,
bu durumda 56,99 TL’lik tutar
57 TL’ye yuvarlanır.
Siz siparişi tamamla butonuna bastığınız
anda ise gömleğin bedeli marka tarafından
tahsil edilirken bağışınızın yüzde yüzü
doğrudan seçtiğiniz STK’nın
banka hesabına gider.
“Yuvarla” bu bağışlardan herhangi
bir hizmet bedeli
ya da komisyon almaz.
Siz de kredi kartı ekstrenize
baktığınız zaman
bağışınızın güvenle yerine
gittiğini görebilirsiniz.
Son derece basit ve şeffaf bir yöntem.
Bu görmüş olduğunuz senaryo
şimdiye kadar Yuvarla’nın
finansal hesap verilebilirlik
kriterlerine uygun,
yani aldığı bağışı nerede nasıl
kullandığını beyan edebilen ve elbette
gerekli yasal izinlere sahip 14 STK için
yarım milyondan fazla çevrimiçi alışveriş
işleminde gerçekleşti bile.
Elbette şunu söyleyebilirsiniz:
Bağış miktarları gerçekten küçük.
Yüz binlerce insan küsüratlı tutarlarını
yuvarlayarak neyi değiştirmiş olabilir ki?
Örnek verecek olursak:
Küsüratlarını yuvarlayan
her 100 kişiden 23’ü,
daha iyi bir çevre ve yaşayan bir
gezegen için kuruşlarını bağışladı.
Her geçen gün ormanlarımız giderek
azalırken sadece TEMA Vakfı'na
bağışlanan minik kuruşlarla
16 futbol sahası
büyüklüğünde bir alan ağaçlandırıldı.
Yani bu minik kuruşlar bize nefes oldu.
Yuvarlayan her 100 kişiden 19’u ise
afet ve insani yardım
alanında faaliyet gösteren
STK’ları destekledi.
Her yıl 300’ün üzerinde arama kurtarma
operasyonuna çıkan AKUT,
sadece bu minik kuruşlarla 10
operasyonunu finanse etti.
Belki de sizin kuruşlarınızla
alınmış bir kar aracı,
kışın Bingöl’ün kırsalında kar
yüzünden mahsur kalmış
hamile bir kadını hastaneye yetiştirdi
ve siz bir hayat kurtardınız.
Her 100 kişiden 26’sı ise
eğitim, çocuk ve gençlik
alanında faaliyet gösteren
STK’ları destekledi.
Koruncuk -yani Türkiye Korunmaya Muhtaç
Çocuklar- Vakfı'na yapılan bağışlar,
ailesi olmadığından ya da özel bir
sebepten ötürü devlet korumasında
yetişmek zorunda kalan çocuklar için sıcak
bir yuva ve iyi bir eğitime dönüştü.
Koruncuk Vakfı'nın kurmuş olduğu
Bolluca Çocuk Köyü’nde
yaşayan 128 çocuktan 4’ünün geleceğini
yuvarlayanlar aydınlattı.
Her 100 kişiden 32’si ise sağlık alanında
faaliyet gösteren STK’ları destekledi.
Yüz tanesiyle bir sakız alamadığımız
bağışlanan bu 1 kuruşlar,
Kanserli Çocuklara Umut Vakfı için
birikerek 110.000 TL’nin
üzerinde bir kaynak
yani tam 20 kanser hastası çocuk
ve ailesine umut oldu.
Bu bahsettiğim örnekler günlük
hayatımızdaki minik tercihlerimizle
yaratabileceğimiz büyük değişimlerin
yalnızca küçük bir kısmı.
Hep beraber bundan daha
fazlasını yapabiliriz.
Artık sadece Yuvarla’nın anlaşmalı olduğu
e-ticaret sitelerinde değil;
sokakta yani mahalle bakkalından
restorana, benzinciden eczaneye
kadar kartların geçtiği her yerde
küsüratlı harcamalarınızı yuvarlayarak
yani sadece kuruşlarınızla çözüme
ortak olabilirsiniz.
Tamam bu kadarını ben de yaparım,
ben de varım derseniz
yapmanız gereken şey çok kolay.
Yuvarla.com adresine girerek desteklemek
istediğiniz STK’yı seçin,
küsüratlı harcamalarınızda her seferinde
size sorularak mı yuvarlanacağını yoksa
aylık 3 TL gibi belirleyebileceğiniz bir
üst limit dâhilinde kuruşların
otomatik olarak mı yuvarlanacağını seçin
ve kartınızı sisteme ekleyin,
en fazla 2 dakikanızı alır.
Bundan sonra ise hiçbir şey
yapmanıza gerek yok.
Siz günlük hayatınıza devam ederken,
örneğin 8,90 TL’ye bir kahve aldığınızda
eğer otomatik yuvarlayı
tercih etmediyseniz
telefonunuza bir bildirim gelebilir.
Ve artık siz sadece şikâyet etmek yerine,
sadece parmağınızla onay tuşuna basarak
10 kuruşunuzla çözüme ortak olabilirsiniz.
Bu yeni dijital bağış kumbarası modeliyle
artık minik kuruşların potansiyeli
eskisinden çok daha büyük.
Rakamlarla örnek vermek gerekirse,
Türkiye’de aktif olarak kullanılan 81
milyon banka ve kredi kartı var.
Sadece geçen yıl bu kartlarla 4,4
milyardan fazla kartlı harcama yapılmış.
Düşünsenize bunlardan sadece bir kısmını
yuvarlayarak neleri değiştirebilirdik?
Hatta şöyle örnek vereyim:
Sahip olduğumuz her bir kartla ayda sadece
1 TL bağışlamayı kabul edersek
toplumsal ve çevresel
problemlerin çözümü için
kullanılabilecek her yıl 972 Milyon TL’lik
bir kaynak yaratabiliriz.
Kuruşlarla yaklaşık 1 Milyar TL’lik bir
kaynaktan bahsediyorum.
Bununla ne yaparız derseniz…
Arkamda Belgrad Ormanı’nı görüyorsunuz.
İstanbul’un rahat nefes almasını
sağlayan akciğerleri…
Sadece minik kuruşlarla yaratılan
bu kaynakla her yıl
13 Belgrad Ormanı büyüklüğünde
bir alanı ağaçlandırabiliriz.
Düşünsenize her yıl 13 yeni orman,
kulağa çok hoş geliyor.
Ya da beni STK’larla tanıştıran,
üniversitede gönüllü öğretmenlik yaptığım
Türkiye Eğitim Gönüllüleri Vakfı'nın
mottosunu size hatırlatayım.
“Bir çocuk değişir, dünya değişir.” diyor.
Biz minik kuruşlarla yarattığımız
bu kaynakla her yıl
800 binden fazla çocuğun daha iyi bir
eğitim almasını sağlayabiliriz.
Burada Türkiye’nin geleceği olacak
neredeyse bir nesilden bahsediyorum.
800 bin çocuk…
Sadece kuruşlarla yapılabilecek bundan
daha iyi bir yatırım olabilir mi?
Hiç sanmıyorum.
Bu bahsettiğim bir hayal değil.
Eğer biz problemlerin seyiricisi değil,
çözümlerin ortağı olmaya başlarsak
hayaller gerçek olur!
Bunun için tek yapmamız gereken,
“değiştirmeyi” tercih etmek.
Tıpkı şimdiye kadar yuvarlayanların
yaptığı gibi.
Bana soruyorlar Yuvarla’yı neden
yapıyorsun, hikâyesi nedir diye.
Sanırım geçmişte yaşadığım
bir hikâyenin beni
bu yola ittiğini söylememi bekliyorlar.
Oysaki anlatacak dramatik bir hikâyem yok.
Fakat şunu söyleyebilirim, siz
oturma odanızın ortasında
bir çöp görürseniz ne yaparsınız?
Sanırım eğilip alırsınız.
Aslına bakılırsa almayabilirsiniz de,
bu bir tercihtir.
Ben kendi oturma odam olan bu toplumda
çözülebileceğine inandığım
bir problemle karşılaştım, benim tercihim
bu hikâyenin başlangıcı oldu.
Siz de kendi tercihlerinizle,
kendiniz ya da
başkaları için güzel hikâyeleri
mümkün kılabilirsiniz.
Teşekkürler!
(Alkış)